les biens et maintenant
si mike horn
france soir bonsoir efforts voilà un
personnage par les français maintenant
oui comme une vache espagnole
alors justement vous êtes né en 1966 à
johannesburg en afrique du sud alors
avant de parler votre aventure qui est
exceptionnel mike horn
vous pensez quoi de ce qui est devenu
l'afrique du sud aujourd'hui le pays
arc-en-ciel dont parle
nelson mandela où les blancs sont restés
il ya toujours des indiens des métis des
noirs est ce que ça marche
écoute je viens de rentrer de l'afrique
sud après trois ans dans l'arctique
ouais et puis je voulais rester il ya
beaucoup d'espoir là il ya beaucoup de
développement il ya beaucoup
d'investisseurs qui arrive et puis je
crois que ça marche bien
nelson mandela je le connais un peu il a
vraiment fait une bonne pour le travail
puis j'espère que thabo m'beki il va
continuer avec ça et puis on doit juste
faire d'autres petites choses pour le
sida et tout ça est parfois il faut
mettre un peu de plus d'argent là dedans
et puis un peu plus de promotions vers
en tous les cas à nelson mandela a dit
mon fils est mort du sida alors que
souvent en afrique du sud ont dit les
morts de la tuberculose parce qu'on
n'ose pas dire que c'est le sida et
nelson mandela avoué que son fils était
mort du sida c'est ça c'est triste mais
il m'apparaît donc l'afrique du sud ça
marche
aujourd'hui ouais je crois que trois
manches puis voilà donc mike horn est ce
qu'on appelle un aventurier de l'extrême
c'est un type extraordinaire la preuve
il a déjà descendu l'amazone à la nage
il a fait le tour du monde en suivant la
ligne de l'équateur
hélas hélas vous venez de faire vingt
mille kilomètres autour du cercle
polaire arctique
c'est la fameuse expédition arctos ce1
alors vous raconter ça dans un bouquin
qui est publié chez x o qui s'appelle
conquérant de l'impossible alors il ya
deux phrases en exergue de ce bouquin la
première c'est une phrase de alexis de
tocqueville
nous appelons impossible ce qui n'a
jamais été tenté
voilà et la deuxième aile et d'andrée
chedid la grand mère de m
je dis ça pour les plus jeunes
l'impossible est le seul adversaire
digne de l'homme
voilà les deux phrases qui l'a collé en
exergue de 200 bouka alors au départ
êtes d'origine hollandaise c'est des
hollandais qui sont partis habiter en en
amérique du sud ouest français on est au
rendez vous pardon comme dave mais je ne
peux pas dans le même coin mais bon on
n'est pas trop alors votre père était
directeur de lycée c'était annexes
springbok il est mort quand vous aviez
15 ans et votre mère était enseignante à
leurs enfants vous étiez déjà très
sportif mike horn et son avenir de
d'aventuriers se dessine assez tôt à 8
ans vous rejoignez en vélo la ferme de
votre oncle qui est située à 300 km de
là 1 300 kilomètres séparent nous incite
à dit orgueil j'ai commencé notre
octobre plus que les nerfs exane afrique
alors quand vous étiez adolescent vous
êtes rentré dans dans l'armée je l'étais
capitaine des forces spéciales
sud-africaine effet la guerre en namibie
donc ça vous a effectivement formé à la
violence
voilà et puis ensuite vous rentrez dans
la vie professionnelle et la mike horn
est employé par son oncle il fait de
l'import export de fruits et légumes au
départ vers vous réaliser une
transaction exceptionnelle sur des choux
qui vous a rapporté énormément d'argent
voyager trop vite trop vieille animavie
mais voilà ça lui plaisait pas parce que
bon il avait plein de blé n'y avait pas
de but dans la vie est là vous
établissez il avait pas de cul
l'eau chaude
ap ap huit mois donc là vous établissez
une liste des endroits de la jungle et
des étendues glacées vous aimeriez aller
et puis vous réunissez tous vos amis un
jour oui quoi j'ai eu tout ce que je
voulais pas les skis mais c'était pas ça
que je voulais et puis je disais mais ce
soir je fais un grand fête chez moi et
puis je me en acheter un à johannesburg
une grande maison il ya une piscine et
où je disais à mes potes écoute bien et
puis ce soir je donne tout ce que j'ai à
toutes mes potes et puis on a bu un
petit verre et tout ça ma soeur est avec
avocate ira préfère préparer toutes les
contraintes
j'ai donné qu à mes amis et puis je me
retrouvais avec un sac à l'aéroport il a
tout donné alors à ce moment-là ce
qu'ont connu à ce moment là mais ces
créations live à l'aéroport et les seuls
pays en fait on pouvait aller quand on
était africain du sud sans visa c'était
israël la suisse et l'angleterre donc
yves à l'aéroport à ce moment là il ya
un avion qui part pour la suisse
c'est comme ça que vous vous retrouvez à
zurich exactement exactement 100 sans
rien connaître de la langue sans rien
connaître du pays
alors début c'était difficile quand même
à vous et j'ai commencé il y à il ya 360
km entre zurich et montres ou non et
puis parce que j'ai pas eu du travail
vie j'ai pas eu l'argent
j'ai décidé de faire ça à pied et puis
de passer un peu vers les paysans pour
demander s'il y avait du travail 1 puis
c'est de toujours un peu la même réponse
highlander erhard canada qui est normal
il disait que quoi on engage pas des
étrangers
1 et puis là je disais d'accord et
coûteux pourquoi je continue arriver
j'arrivais à montreux j'ai commencé de
volée juste pour rester vivants voyez
vous évoluer des fruits il faut que j'ai
dormi dans des étapes j'ai dormi sous
des ponts pas c'est incroyable parce que
il ya quelque chose d'extraordinaire
cirque en afrique du sud
vous faisiez partie de la la classe des
possédants la classe des riches des
blancs à l'époque un c'était bon on en
parle à part
et puis un jour vous arrivez en suisse
et vous retrouver dans la position du
noir quoi dans la position du titre
capable
oui mais écoute c'est sûr c'est sûr que
si tu te trouve dans une situation un
peu que t'as pas vraiment l'habitude de
dire soit tout rentre à la maison bien à
ce que je lui rien à la maison jeudi
il faut que j'arrête mes responsabilités
vous aviez comme on dit brûler vos
vaisseaux c'est à dire que vous n'aviez
plus de maison dans laquelle retournez
donc j'étais obligé de continuer vous
faites des petits boulots vous installez
ensuite vous rencontrer katy qui
deviendra votre votre femme vous
commencez à trouver des sponsors en face
et un courage absolument extraordinaire
il l'a vous vivez votre première grande
aventure en 1997 traversée de l'amérique
du sud à trois il part du pérou il fait
déjà 600 bornes à travers la cordillère
des andes mais comme ça tu vois j'ai
commencé pour y aller au pérou en avion
ouais j'ai une copain qui était pilote
et puis voilà il fait 600 morts dans la
cordillère des andes jusqu'aux sources
de l'amazone et là vous descendez
l'amazone l'idée c'était 6400 km nage
l'idée c'était dedans fait traverser
l'amérique du sud
ouais en solitaire sans assistance et
puis il des bouées quand même il avait
un truc s'appelle l'hydrospeed c'est une
petite planche tu sais un body board
comment dix églises comme ça et c'est
les jambes series et son visage anti ivg
liste déjà timidement il ya un animal
qui est pas mal intéressant parce que la
dia tu vas y tu peux pas vraiment fait
pipi dans l'eau parce qu'il ya ces
poissons de chats mara site dès que tu
fais pipi en fait là you're in salah
tirelire entre et s'arranger oui il ya
un trou ouais
et puis en fait tu peux pisser dans le
vent mais il faut regarder ton patins en
main et ça c'est comme tu peux chier sur
la place rouge
donc il fait quand même six ans il fait
quand même 6400 km à la nage donc
l'accent en hydrospeed pour descendre
l'amazone jusqu'à l'embouchure de
l'amazone dans l'océan dans le sens
atlantique ses premières aventures de ce
prix si besoin
deuxième grande aventure qui a encore un
exploit absolument unique
le tour du monde en solitaire par
l'équateur son véhicule à moteur à
l'idée c'était de rester sur l'équateur
et pas de m'éloigner plus vendre 1000
honorera la ville au sud
et puis de deux parties d gabon et quand
vous quittez le gabon c'est la première
fois que vous vous retrouvez seul sur un
voilier jamais jamais c'est la voile en
fait c'est gégé winch et futurs du
bateau de laurent bourgnon quels sont
les grands gagnants il part du gabon
pour traverser l'atlantique
c'est la première fois qu'il est celle
sur un voilier alors ensuite bon il ya
ya l'amérique du sud vont traverser
l'amérique du sud l'indonésie avec les
révoltes avec les combats tout ça va
être extraordinaire
et puis bon voilà vous êtes élu
aventuriers du xxème siècle voit les
pages y avait par un autre c'est quoi
c'est pour sa part bon on a vu donc la
descente de l'amazone à la nage le tour
du monde par l'équateur est là en
février 2002 sert klose donc c'est la
dernière expédition celle que vous
racontez dans votre bouquin conquérant
de l'impossible donc 20000km tour du
cercle polaire arctique
à contre courant et à contrevent alors
on lui dit mais pourquoi quand on fait
vingt mille kilomètres autour du cercle
polaire arctique pourquoi vous le faites
à contre-courant à contrevent qui
s'entend si bien que ça que ça fait
et alors quand on lui dit qu'on va vous
le faites à contre-courant à contrevent
il dit parce que en cas de réussite dans
l'autre sens
j'aurais passé toute ma vie à me
demander comment j'aurai réussi dans le
mauvais sens ouais ça moi je la mettrais
d échouer un peu contre 1 contre des
aliments que d'aller avec lysanne ai dit
des trucs vie les c'est tellement dur ce
qui fait que trouvent le courage de
surmonter toutes les épreuves et vous
dites je les ai surmonter parce que
j'ignorais quelle souffrance elle
représentait si j'avais su
quelle souffrance j'allais vivre je
l'aurais pas fait si c'est des
accessoires aussi à la maison m'écoute
pas dit comment ça y est je crois j'ai
pas du tout mal y avait il ya des
moments qui est plus dur que les autres
aujourd'hui c'est mon métier et puis je
fais ça professionnellement pendant dix
ans et puis c'est moi je vois ça comme
tout à fait normal qu'on veut des
courses vous prenez un caddie ou mettez
tout comme sa survie alors ce qu'il faut
savoir quand même c'est qu'avant de
faire le tour du cercle
donc voilà il fallait en l'air il ya eu
un voyage préparatoire le voyage
préparatoire il dit bon pour me préparer
un second semestre enfants je vais aller
au pôle nord en solitaire à 800 morts
c'est juste pour s'entraîner jusqu'au
s'entraîner et la grosse erreur je n'ai
pas eu vraiment choix c'était un moment
que je marchais plus ça veut dire que
mon corps génère plus de chaleur et puis
je commence à tomber dans les po thermie
oui et puis là c'est la vie aux ligues
lima 1
j'ai enlevé mes move pour attacher mes
chaussures en effet c'est sur c'est la
dernière fois que je m'enlève et mes
mots tu es là les doigts explose et
alors ce qu'il fait y rentre dans sa
tendre il met ses doigts dans le feu
parce qu'ils sont tellement gelés qui
les met dans le feu et est à ce moment
là oui il a eu il a été un peu amputé
oui et à ce moment là et ça sent la
viande brûlée lui sans rien mais ça s'en
va et ça sent la viande brûlée alors
effectivement l'abus décidé de rentrer
donc cette expédition préparatoire n'a
pas été mené à son
terme de cidre ont trait pour sauver vos
mains en fait ça exactement il ya un
moment que tu dises mais là maintenant
je dois rentrer je dois réparer mes
mains non autrement si je continue je
t'ai à quinze jours du pôle si je
continue je me permets main et puis je
peux plus rien faire de marée tout ça
parce que tu avais des groupes réunis au
micro marche pas à moi 50 ça fait en
fait ça peut être mon champ compte pas
sûr c'est que derrière iron pour entrer
on vous ampute un peu le bout des doigts
mais vous attendez même pas le délai
normal vous partez pour cette fameuse
expédition donc archos et là il ya des
épreuves absolument inouïe celui d'hier
c'est par exemple un moment il va en
bateau départ de de norvège moyenne
landes
il ya un trou dans la coque est là alors
c'est incroyable cirque d'une main et
conduit le bateau de l'autre ils vident
le bateau et il ya les icebergs qui
arrive sur lui et le mec il au milieu il
ya mieux c'est là il ya céline dion
dormir parce que s'il dort il pu piloter
le bateau pu vider le bateau donc voila
et puis au milieu des icebergs comme
sahbi nazif dix fois un peu on n'a pas
vraiment le choix du foie puis on est
arrivé à nantes
c'est vraiment fou jouer à chat [ __ ] ou
quoi
alors après il traverse le guayana où il
devait recevoir une langue d'avec une
espèce de cerfs-volants quoi et ça va
très vite parce que vous arrivez à faire
d un jour par exemple il fait 18 heures
dans la journée 143 km donc ça va assez
vite vous battez le record de traversée
du groenland
grâce à ce système de cerfs-volants et
puis un jour il ya un vent énorme
looping voilà je vais t'arracher s'est
arrachée par une tempête de vent
exactement là c'était juste un moment
que tu peut plus gérer la surface est
trop grandes mains de mecar et vivent
sur x 60 70 kilomètres à l'heure et tu
peux plus de sont à voile c'est sûr
qu'il ya un moment que tu vas passer du
travail tu vas passer d'un mode de
développement et de production
et puis là c'est sûr tu tout un temps il
s'en sort à chaque fois c'est
extraordinaire à un moment il arrive
dans une région il doit prendre un
bateau pour aller à calamity belge croit
il doit prendre un bateau et puis bon il
ya la glace qui fait qu'on peut pas
naviguer
il fait un détour de 1200 km le mec avec
jets par des tours de 300 mètres
alentours de 1200 km et tout ça à moins
60 dans la nuit permanente parce qu'en
plus de ça il faut voir ce que c'était
même pas jour il neige il fait froid
moins 60 chez nuit là malheureusement on
a trois mois de nuit ou n'a pas beaucoup
de soleil mais on aurait pu y décrit sur
l'essor et à bangkok 24 heures sur 24
et là tu veux bien avancé alors c'est
extraordinaire parce que ce sont des
régions où la vie humaine est impossible
cirque les seuls qui vivent là-bas ce
sont les inuits
mais ils bougent pas ils restent où ils
vivent sur leur graisse comme les ours
quoi ils vivent tout l'hiver sur leur
glace
en attendant qu'il fasse beau choix et
lui non lui il avance là dedans dans ce
pays donc elle même pas un il 8 qui fait
ce que vous avez fait quoi
c'est parce que les ennemis saupin
compte déjà un ep en plus les inuit
chasse au début de l'hiver là et puis
l'hiver
iris parce qu'il peut plus
il voit rien ouais et puis moi si je
restais je crevais 5
j'ai été obligé d'un marché en fait de
rester vivant 1